ميدانيا اعلنت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
دنيتسكس استهداف القوات الاوكرانيه
المقاطعه احدى عشره مره خلال اليوم الماضي
واشارت هذه السلطات الى ان الجيش
الاوكراني قصف ثلاثه احياء سكنيه بنحو 65
قديفه ما الحق اضرارا ماديه بمبان سكنيه
هذا اعلن موقع العسكريه الروسي اصابه
اربعه مدنيين جراء قصف مدفعي اوكرانيا
استهدف مدينه ميليتوبل للجنوب مقاطعه
الموقع نقلا عن مصادر في السلطات المدينه
ان المبنى القريب من الكليه تعرض لدمار
جزئي
ومنبخ لقائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
الدفاع عن المدينه ضروره عسكريه وان
المعارك مستمره فيها ولفت المسؤول
الاوكراني خلال تفاقده المدينه الى ان
الوضع في بخموت صعب لكن الجانب الروسي
الذي يواصل القيام بعمل هجوميه يتكبد
خسائر كبيره في الارواح والاسلحه
والمعدات العسكريه وفق قوله
معنى من غرب مراسل الجزيره حسن الشوبكي
ومن دنيا مراسله الجزيره رانيا ارحب بكم
نبدا معك حسن الشوبكي اخر التصريحات على
المستوى الرسمي والبيانات العسكريه
المتعلقه بتطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا
نعم ازدهار يعني حيث نحن نتواجد في غرب اخ
متت باخمه لا زالت هي
المعركه الاكثر سخونه والاكثر صعوبه كما
قال بيان عسكري صدر قبل قليل وهذا البيان
تحدث ان المعارك ما تزال مستمره في باخموت
وان
الجبهه الاشد على بين كل الجبهات شرقا
وشمالا وجنوبا في
اوكرانيا هي في باخمت لكن هذا هذه الزياره
التي قام بها
قائد القوات البريه الى المواقع المتقدمه
في اتجاه باقي يعني على خط النار الاول
كما يعني اوضح البيان هذه الزياره تشير
الى انه اتخذ عده عده تدابير لتفعيل
منظومات القتال في هذه المناطق للالويه
والكتائب الموجوده في مناطق متقدمه في
باخمت لم يتحدث البيان العسكري عن اي ما
هي التدابير التي
هؤلاء قتلى اوردتهم الارقام التراكميه
للجيش الاوكراني انهم سقطوا في هذه
المواجهات يضاف الى ذلك ان هنالك نقل
للعمليات والى فكه وامريكا حيث تحاول
القوات الروسيه محاصره مدينه
المتوقع يعني
ازدهار ان تكون
ثانيه لان الحصار عليها بدا منذ اسابيع
والان تقصف بشكل مكثف ونرك محاولات من
الطرف الروسي للسيطره عليها هي ستكون باقي
الثاني كما يقول القاده العسكريون هنا في
شرق البلاد هذا ما يقوله هو القاده
العسكريون في شرق البلاد ولكن ما هي
المعطيات العسكريه الروسيه رانيا وكذلك
ماذا تقول الخارجيه الروسيه بشان العقوبات
الغربيه
بدايه فيما يتعلق بالوضع الميداني اود
الاشاره الى ان مدينه دانيسك يعني يمكن
القول انها تتعرض لقصف مكثف عن خلال
الساعه الماضيه الحديث يدور عثمان عن قصف
حي اكالينز الذي يقع في قلب المدينه وهو
يقع هذا الحي على يعني بعد امتار عن
مستشفى الاطفال في مدينه دانياسك تم قصبه
باربع صواريخ السلطات حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يتم التاكيد ولكن المعطيات الاوليه تشير
الى انه تم استهدافه باستخدام راجمات
صواريخ امريكيه الصنع
عمده مدينه قبل قليل اشاره الى ان هناك
ضحايا في صفوف المدنيين ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تصدر معطيات رسميه فيما يتعلق
باعداد القتلى والجرح جراء هذا
القصف من جهه اخرى وقبل نحو ساعتين من
الان ايضا تعرض حي كيدز كثير العاصمه ايضا
الصواريخ تم اطلاق عشره صواريخ على هذا
الحي اذا هناك قصف مكثف خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه لهذه المدينه من قبل
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه هذا تزامن مع
اعلان السلطات المحليه عن استهداف المنطقه
خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه
باكثر من 60 قذيفه من اعير مختلفه طالت
ثلاثه احياء سكنيه في مختلف ارجاء المدينه
ومقاطعه دانيت من التزامن مع ذلك ايضا
فيما يتعلق
بالتزامن مع الاعلان امس من قبل الجانب
الروسي ان مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رافايل جروسي عزمه التوجه في زياره
الى محطه
النوويه اليوم تم التاكيد على ان مدينه
ميليتوبل الذي تقع جنوب في المناطق
الجنوبيه من مقاطعه تم استهدافها بالم
دفعيه الاوكرانيه هذا الاستهداف يعني طالب
مبنى سكني بالقرب من كليه في هذه المدينه
وتم اجلاء العديد من الطلاب على الفور
الحديث يدور عن نحو اجلاء 50 طالب من هذه
الكليه شكرا لك اذا من دونافسك مراسله
الجزيره رانيا دريدي شكرا ايضا لمراسله
الجزيره حسن الشوبكي كان معنا من غربي
ضخمه